à partir de minuit ce soir là on dit
autorise 6500 réfugiés et allemand a
quitté le pays en direction de
l'allemagne de l'ouest qui s'attend à un
afflux considérable citoyens venus de
rda à bonn en cite les chiffres de 1 à 2
millions dernière grande manifestation
du bicentenaire de la révolution
française la bataille de valmy fêter
avec trois ans d'avancé une grande
presse que la gloire de l'armée de la
république
repoussant l'envahisseur frud siens
alain prost en délicatesse avec son
employeur mclaren depuis qu'il a annoncé
son transfert chez ferrari
crions malgré tout à monza il a
désormais toutes les chances d'être une
nouvelle fois champion du monde voilà
monsieur bonsoir la première information
de ce dimanche soir vient de budapest le
gouvernement hongrois vient de décider
en effet d'autoriser les 6500 citoyens
est-allemands réfugié sur son territoire
à le quitter pour la destination de leur
choix
collectivement individuellement par tous
les moyens qu'ils voudront cette
décision prendra effet à minuit ce soir
et l'on sait que principalement ces
hommes et ces femmes ont l'intention de
se rendre en allemagne de l'ouest où les
autorités ont annoncé dès la semaine
dernière qu'elle était prête à les
accueillir à bonn on estime que ces
quelques milliers de personnes ne
représentent que le début d'une
émigration qui pourrait d'ici à quelques
années s'amplifier pour atteindre le
chiffre de 1 voire 2 millions véronique
taveau la liberté enfin ils vont pouvoir
partir quitter la grille et c'est quand
passer à l'ouest
ce moment les réfugiés des camps de
budapest l'attendait depuis plusieurs
semaines il aura fallu de longues
négociations entre l'allemagne de l'est
l'allemagne de l'ouest et la hongrie
pour parvenir un accord ce soir langeree
cède aux pressions internationales et
une grossesse frontières laissant ainsi
partir des ressortissants d'un autre
pays de l'est ce d'un pays frère
un fait sans précédent à partir de
minuit trois postes frontière entre la
hongrie et l'autriche vont être
spécialement ouvert ce soir
pas besoin de visa les réfugiés sont
même autorisés à partir avec leur propre
voiture
les convois la liberté comme ils les ont
eux mêmes baptisée vont enfin passer à
l'ouest
pour les milliers de réfugiés une
nouvelle
commence de l'autre côté en allemagne de
l'ouest
tout est prêt pour les recevoir la
bavière s'apprête à accueillir le plus
grand exode de réfugiés en europe depuis
la construction du mur de berlin en 1961
il ya quelques minutes à peine le
ministre des affaires étrangères ouest
allemand monsieur dietrich genscher a
déclaré ce soir donc son pays
l'oublierai pas cette décision de la
hongrie décisions courageuses dit-il
prise sous sa propre responsabilité
cette décision de la hongrie intervient
au moment où l'union soviétique connell
une aggravation de ses problèmes
économiques monsieur gorbatchev ayant
annoncé à la télévision des mesures qui
risquent d'être très impopulaire le
numéro un soviétique s'est confirmée qui
doit rencontrer au mois de novembre le
pape jean paul ii au vatican à
l'occasion d'une visite officielle en
italie
l'information annoncée par l'ambassadeur
du rss la politique française est
dominée ce dimanche par le retour sur le
devant de la scène de monsieur jacques
chirac le rpr et son allié le parti
républicain le père dirigée par françois
léotard se rencontrait aujourd'hui au
canet plage pour tenter de trouver 10
ont une même définition de l'union de
l'opposition
c'est à cette occasion que l'ancien
premier ministre et candidat à la
présidence de la république a redit avec
clarté qu'il entendait bien faire la
course en tête et présenter une
véritable alternance au pouvoir
socialiste véronique saint olive gibert
usant sur place l'opposition ne tourne
plus rond les électeurs grogne alors ils
se retrouvent pour relancer le manège de
l'union côte à côte sur la même tribune
il sourit udf rpr au coude à coude les
au micro déjà ils expriment leurs
différences pour léotard l'union ce
n'est pas un mariage d'amour mais une
association d'intérêts bien compris
que l'on ne pénalise pas le succès à
l'intérieur de l'opposition je souhaite
que le rpr soit fort je le dis devant
eux et je souhaite qu'ils aient
vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes la même attitude
et le même respect jacques chirac lui
veut prendre de la hauteur
il n'est pas contre l'union des familles
de nos positions mais ce n'est pas pour
lui l'essentiel ma part je suis tout à
fait décidée à apporter mon appui sans
réserve à toutes les initiatives et ceci
dit qu'elles viennent et qu'ils
renforcent l'union de l'opposition
mais cette union n'était évidemment pas
une fin en soi ce n'est qu'un moyen pour
mettre en oeuvre une politique et la
politique pour chirac
ce sont les grandes affaires de la
france les rapports est ouest le chômage
la drogue
une façon pour lui de gommer déjà son
image de président de parti pour celle
de président tout court
alors l'union bien sûr ils sont tous
pour mes françois léotard c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il devra d'abord la
réaliser au sein de l'udf s'ils veulent
a négocié un jour avec jacques chirac
la traditionnelle fête du journal
communiste l'humanité à la courneuve
dans la banlieue parisienne
la première journée hier samedi avait
été consacrée au bouillonnement dont
sont l'objet les pays de l'est et
l'union soviétique
monsieur marché s'était déclaré heureux
que les choses bougent même si c'est de
manière tumultueuse la journée
d'aujourd'hui a été disons plus
classiques les dirigeants du pc ont
critiqué la politique sociale du premier
ministre michel rocard reportage de
bruno roger petit et bernard banques
une rentrée musclée le pc l'avait comme
promis à la sortie d'un été chaud
la fête de l'huma serait le prélude à un
automne social tout aussi chaud mais
aujourd'hui chaleur rim est avec torpeur
ambiance de concert façon août stocks
dans le style des années soixante dix
avec charlélie couture la politique
n'était pas encore au rendez vous mais
elle a vite repris ses droits
les 10 de renault et leurs camarades ont
dégagé le terrain ils ont fait place
nette pour antoine casanova chargée de
prononcer le traditionnel discours de
rentrée charge contre les travaux
d'hercule de michel rocard qui
n'impressionne pas vraiment les
communistes quand on fait le bilan
détaillé des projets gouvernementaux
on voit bien qu'ils ne vont vraiment pas
dans la bonne voie ce sont bien les
travaux d'hercule pour les profits mais
c'est lilliput pour les salaires
après l international de rigueur
reprises en playback partout l'état
major du parti communiste c'est jacques
higelin qui a pris sur scène le relais
du coup la torpeur de l'après midi s'en
est trouvée dissiper yves blain a
réveillé la fête de l'huma à une petite
exception près
agence de presse roumaine vient
d'annoncer une collision entre deux
navires sur le danube pour l'instant le
nombre des disparus a été chiffré à 164
personnes on ne compte pour l'instant
que 18 rescapés les élections de la
semaine dernière en afrique du sud avait
engendré des manifestations des noirs
qui n'était pas conviée à voter ces
manifestations avaient fait 22 morts le
pouvoir blanc affirmant qu'il n'était
pour rien dans cette affaire qu'il
s'agissait de heurts entre noire version
controversée par les organisations anti
ségrégationniste aujourd'hui avait lieu
les obsèques de l'une de ses victimes
une jeune fille
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux martin
laroche joubert et alain le ghetto des
cartes fontaine c'est ici qu'est morte
mercredi dernier jour des élections une
jeune fille de 16 ans enceinte de cinq
mois
l'une des 29 victimes dénoncé par
l'archevêque desmond tutu la famille les
voisins près par l'enterrement une mort
dont les circonstances ne sont pas
éclaircies
d'après les témoins elle marché dans le
quartier à nouveau tranquille après les
troubles de la journée deux policiers
arrivent en voiture sur elle s'écroule
une version contestée par la police pour
qui cette mort comme toutes celles de ce
jour là a été provoquée par des bagarres
entre factions rivales
nous sommes ici depuis quelques minutes
à peine quand la police arrive
en afrique du sud où l'état d'urgence
est décrété depuis près dé quatre ans il
est interdit de filmer des
manifestations ce n'est pas le cas ici
pourtant ils seront arrêtés et emmenés
dans un poste de police une heure et
demie q relâché avec nos cassettes à 80
km du cap
l'enterrement cette fois ci la police
interviendra par pourtant elle encercle
la township une semaine de deuil
commence demain dans la communauté noire
mercredi jour d'ouverture du parlement
au cap et de la prise de fonction
officielle du président de clerck
ils marchent d'ores et déjà interdite
est prévue dans le centre de la ville
elle sera menée par l'archevêque
anglican desmond toutous et peut-être
par là même qui a déjà condamné les
violences
le maire de la ville du cap en blanc la
semaine passée en france a été marquée
par la continuation de la polémique
autour des propos antisémites du
réalisateur de cinéma claude autant lara
d'une manière plus générale depuis
quelques années maintenant aucun pays
d'europe n'était pas remis par la
résurgence d'une certaine forme
d'idéologie néonazis qui pose à sa
manière le problème des immigrés dont il
juge le nombre trop important
aucun pays n'est épargné donc y compris
la tranquille suisse en apparence du
moins
la suisse qui compte un million
d'immigrés pour cinq millions
d'habitants la question voulez vous ou
non fermer les frontières a même été
posé brutalement l'année dernière au
suisse par voie de référendum en quête
de valérie fournier et maryse richard
dans la cité de transit de quoi on se
souvient encore de l' incendie un acte
criminel qui a tué quatre personnes dont
deux enfants et amour
et l'on a peur on se fait le plus
discret possible en attendant un
difficile et parfois hypothétique permis
de séjour en fonction des quotas puisque
les droits de l'homme existe dans le
monde on a normalement le droit de venir
travailler ici là dessus pourquoi
vouloir nous jeter hors des frontières
moi je n'ai pas d'autres joueurs je ne
peux pas retourner en turquie
je suis kurde un droit de plus en plus
difficile à faire admettre dans ce pays
où les immigrés représentent 20% de la
population
pourtant l'an dernier les suisses leur
ont dit oui par référendum et à une
écrasante majorité
mettant ainsi en échec l'initiative de
l'action nationale un parti qui affiche
tous à l'étranger bouffe pas mater
patrie nulle part ailleurs au monde vous
ne pouvez trouver un chiffre aussi élevé
qu'en suisse dans 30 ans nous nous
retrouverons avec deux millions
d'émigrés c'est beaucoup trop pour
l'environnement l'action nationale à une
représentation parlementaire un député
au conseil national depuis deux ans
quelques groupuscules d'extrême droite
vont encore plus loin que les hommes
naissent libres et égaux en droits une
notion que certains ne sont pas prêts à
laisser passer en suisse alémanique où
les grossistes mondialistes
faisant de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme wade par l'assemblée concernant
16 et 12 28 août 1786 sont bien les
droits de l'homme qui combattent
vous voyez c'est ça qui est nouveau et
c'est ça qui est dangereux en suisse
presque chaque samedi il y à des groupes
de jeunes dans différentes villes
surtout en suisse alémanique qui
défilent et qui viennent distribuer une
idéologie fasciste et ils se défendent
d'être des néo nazis
seulement ce sont des jeunes qui ont
toutes les caractéristiques des néo
nazis
un combat qui se fait de plus en plus au
grand jour même à la télévision
le leader du front patriotique rochant
visage d'un homme simplement parce qu'il
est noir fera la une des quotidiens
helvétiques la réincarnation d'un
certain nationalisme existe nous l'avons
rencontré pour cela il a fallu aller
dans ce que l'on appelle la suisse
primitive le berceau de la confédération
par levante des heures avec un homme
extrêmement méfiant une fois rassuré
marcel strebel ne cache pas ses
convictions et comme symbole la croix
fléchées
ça c'est la culture
ça c'est le peuple c'est la nation le
nationalisme ça c'est la religion le
christianisme aux trois fois les
chrétiens se sont battus avec les armes
contre ceux d'autres religieux
aujourd'hui les invite chine et si cette
politique laxiste d'immigration continue
jusqu'en l'an 2000 nous chrétiens et
bergeron nos propres meurtrier chaque
être humain une fierté nationale
certains l'ont plus d'autres moins je
suis heureux qu autrefois des gens comme
guillaume tell se soient battus pour
l'indépendance avec des sentiments
nationaux et nous le ferons patriotique
espérons ne pas être contraints
d'utiliser un lutte armée
la nostalgie du passé d'une suisse au
suisse et sans intrus
ces chauffeurs de poids lourds anciens
lutteurs se dit le porte parole d'un
pays d'une race est prêt à constituer
des groupes d'autodéfense même s'il ne
représente que lui
quelques amis dans les alpages les côtes
sa voix se fait parfois entendre même si
on admet qu'avec une certaine réticence
je ne suis pas d'accord sur tout avec
marcel jeu très belle mais en ce qui
concerne les noirs la race noire doit
vivre avec les noirs comme nous les
suisses d'entraîneur j'ai de la pitié
pour les réfugiés mais s'ils n'ont pas
travaillé bien il vaut mieux qu'ils
rentrent chez eux
oui d'un côté c'est bien d'accueillir
les immigrés mais j'ai toujours le
sentiment qu'ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent de nous numerama il y ait 50 ans
cette même peur autorisés à fouiller les
réfugiés d'une répond pierre une époque
que les parlementaires ne veulent en
aucun cas voir resurgir ne veux pas
qu'on puisse nous reprocher à nous à
notre génération
la même chose que nous avons reproché à
nos parents et à nos grands parents il
ya longtemps
la réponse européenne est réfugié ne
peut pas être il faut véritablement
s'indigner s'élever combattre ceux qui
foulent au pied la démocratie ceux qui
foulent au pied la liberté ceux qui
veulent faire renaître ces vieux miasmes
nazi parce qu'ils n'ont rien compris et
parce qu'ils n'ont rien d'autre à faire
que de vivre dans le confort tranquille
on leur a donné et qui cherche les
aventures en cinq ans création de douze
groupuscule néo nazi en suisse dont l'un
fondé symboliquement du jour
anniversaire du début en allemagne de la
persécution officielle des juifs la nuit
de cristal
le tout avec la bénédiction de la
municipalité de winter tour les
autorisant à défiler flambeau pour
ambroise encore à l'étranger le journal
américain washington post croit savoir
qu'il existe un accord secret entre les
états unis et plusieurs pays d'amérique
du sud pour les aider à lutter contre
les trafiquants de drogue
l'armée américaine pourrait ainsi
intervenir de manière limitée et
ponctuel et puis en colombie la lutte
engagée contre les patrons du trafic se
poursuit quarante deux propriétés
appartenant aux principaux chefs de la
mafia ont été saisis cette mafia qui
réagit en établissant un climat de
violence dans le pays faisant
systématiquement exploser les voitures
piégés aux états unis
plus qu'ailleurs la politique n'est plus
simplement réservé aux professionnels
john baez jane fonda se battait contre
la guerre au vietnam aujourd'hui clint
eastwood ou robert redford s'engage dans
la lutte contre la pollution de la
plaine dans son ranch robert redford
vient d'organiser la première rencontre
entre spécialistes américains et
soviétiques à la manière américaine bien
entendu spectaculaire et efficace en
quête de véronique mula à l'heure où le
monde entier a admiré la beauté de
neptune des scientifiques américains et
soviétiques s'inquiétait du mauvais état
de la planète terre et l'écologiste
convaincu qui organisait cette
conférence bilatéral sur le
réchauffement des corses terrestre c'est
robert redford
nous sommes ici pour passer le témoin
des mains des scientifiques qui savent
ce qui se prépare à celle du public de
nous tous qui devons faire quelque chose
l'acteur américain a reçu les
participants dans son ranch de sundance
au coeur des montagnes rocheuses
sans oublier d'inviter les chefs indiens
des tribus voisines redford est connu
pour ses opinions radicales en matière
d'environnement en 80 il a fondé un
institut de gestion des ressources
naturelles qui mars que nous ne pouvons
pas attendre que le gouvernement se
décide au congrès oui les responsables
politiques devant passer à l'action
c'est aux gens eux mêmes à trouver des
solutions deux les émissions de gaz
toxique provoque l'effet de serre qui
réchauffe le globe pour cet académicien
soviétique la menace est comparable aux
dangers nucléaires d'autres kind of
which you you have discrétion les
problèmes sont-ils scientifiques et
politiques sont-ils politique je pense
que pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la planète
nous traitons d'un problème qui est
d'une importance cruciale pour le futur
de l'espèce humaine humankind le
réchauffement est désastreux pour nos
climats sécheresses désertification
disparition des forêts sur la terre au
moment où je vous parle
un arpent de forêt disparaît chaque
seconde réfléchissez à cela un arpent
d'arbres en moins un arpent d'arbres en
moins les conférenciers ont proposé des
solutions reconstituer les forêts
promouvoir d'autres énergies et surtout
exigé que la production de gaz nuisibles
cesse complètement d'ici l'an 2000 pour
éviter le réchauffement du globe par des
moyens technologiques ne serait pas
content
en fait très profitable puisque cela
reviendrait économiser un milliard de
dollars par an c'est à dire l'équivalent
de notre budget militaire
à eux seuls les états unis et l'union
soviétique produisent plus de la moitié
des émissions de gaz toxique de la
planète
les conférenciers ont appelé les
responsables à une coopération
internationale à une véritable perez
troïka dans le domaine de
l'environnement
il demande à boucher à gorbatchev de
créer une alliance pour la sécurité
écologique
la situation est grave mais à sundance
l'air est encore pure et robert redford
est optimiste
c'est le moment d'aller chercher
l'information chez les scientifiques
pour la transmettre au public une paix
pour décider d'une ligne d'action la
seule chose qui peut faire bouger les
politiciens c'est la pression que peut
exercer le plus brillant mais ce dernier
ne peut rien faire tant qu'il n'aura pas
lui-même problème alors je pense que le
moment est à l'espoir est que nous
devons cesser d'être négatif dit non à
bondoufle
oui nous sommes tous dans la même serre
disaient les américains et les
soviétiques alors autant lutter ensemble
contre le danger pour sceller les débuts
d'une coopération
robert redford et le représentant
soviétiques ont bu à la guérison de la
planète
on reste dans le domaine de l'écologie
souvenez-vous aux dernières élections
européennes la liste chasse et nature en
faveur de la chasse en réaction aux
écologistes avaient dans le sud ouest
notamment recueilli près de 75% des voix
et c'était aujourd'hui justement
l'ouverture de la chasse en france dans
le sud-ouest et le sud-est du pays
ouverture qui s'étalera jusqu'au 8
octobre pour cette première journée bien
nos envoyés spéciaux
thierry calmette jacques gérard se sont
rendus à lartigue en gironde
ouverture de la chasse à lartigue région
bénie pour les chasseurs aux confins des
landes de la gironde et du
lot-et-garonne beaucoup de chevreuil du
faisan bien sûr en attendant les
palombes le mois prochain le plaisir de
la chasse c'est d'abord d'en parler
c'est surtout d'en parler mais les
faisons d'élevage vient-il manger dans
les mains de sa soeur le plaisir de la
chasse pour eux est indicible
il faudrait venir vivre un an ici avec
nous pour comprendre distille en fait il
s'agit de parents une re aucune raison
de s'arrêter
élevé à la dure agriculteurs pour la
plupart les chasseurs de l'arctique ne
voit pas d'un très bon oeil la
compassion des écologistes pour les
animaux depuis 32 ans les nemrod
viennent faire préparer leur gibier par
héloïse ducos qui elle n'aime pas tuer
les animaux n'aime pas trop la chasse
mais comprend les chasseurs
et puis de total jamais on a toujours
fait pour manger les rois autrefois
c'était une initiation
pourquoi par le paysage lartigue il
refuse d'être traité d'assassin
il refuse surtout que l'europe de 1992
dicte leur mode de vie
ceux de strasbourg je crois que ils vont
un peu loin nous sommes des européens
nous sommes des européens
nous sommes pour l'europe mais une
europe de la défense de la recherche
vous voudrez mais en ce qui concerne
tous les us et coutumes de chaque région
il faut les conserver coutumes
ancestrales contre écologie et
planification un problème culturel et le
débat est loin d'être terminée nous n'en
sommes qu'à l'ouverture
les deux derniers à grande manifestation
du bicentenaire de la révolution
française la première a eu lieu hier au
puy de dôme fête de la fraternité qui
commémorait la création est des
départements français ce fut un grand
succès populaire plus de 80000
spectateurs
reportage de claire sébastien hébert
numérique dix mille ans d'histoire
géologique 200 ans d'histoire de france
le volcan du puy-de-dôme emblème du
département et le site naturel le plus
visité de l'hexagone
coiffé de 70 bougies géante il fut hier
soir le gâteau d'anniversaire pour la
célébration des valeurs de la révolution
on voulait fêter la découpe du
territoire national en département to
date de septembre 1789
conséquence directe de la nuit du 4 août
redistribution du territoire en
département mais convaincre les
auvergnats de verser 8 millions de
francs pour ses goûts driller à la mode
du pays ne fut pas facile
la fraternité pourtant c'est aussi la
solidarité évidemment ça coûte cher
enfin pour avoir les droits de l'homme
ça qui était cher aussi rebaptisé mon
fraternité le puy-de-dôme a servi de
piste d'envol aux ailes de la liberté
pour un show aérien prélude au grand
concert c'est bien le peuple qui a fait
la révolution de 1789 et bien les
musiques populaires liberté c'est le
langage universel de la musique égalité
c'est un plaisir partagé et fraternité
c'est la conscience d'un destin commun
de son pupitre voisin qui respecte sa
partition pour faire partager un plaisir
le problème était de faire jouer tous
les musiciens du département du puy de
dôme du plus modestes aux plus
expérimentés donc il a fallu écrire une
partition spécifique c'est-à-dire que
l'oeuvre est écrite en fragments
ils ont été adaptés suivant le chaque
société chaque musicien et puis
aujourd'hui on les met tous ensemble
pour cette fête de la fraternité
deux mille cinq cents musiciens amateurs
ont joué la suite galactique reprise en
choeur par 60 min badauds pour une nuit
fraternelle et illuminées
la seconde des dernières grandes
manifestations du bicentenaire est à
venir elle aura lieu à partir de samedi
prochain et jusqu'au 20 septembre à
valmy dans la marne
cette commémoration portent le label du
bicentenaire même si la bataille qui
permit à l'armée de la république
naissante de repousser l'envahisseur
prussiens mais lui en fait qu en 1792 en
présence du président de la république
monsieur mitterrand la première
représentation aura lieu samedi prochain
en direct sur antenne 2 l'après midi
reportage jacques violet et claude à
valmy 89 sera artistique et culturelle
c'est deuxième bataille a été confiée à
des créateurs contemporains assisté par
les militaires pour évoquer sur le site
historique dans ce paysage paisible
l'union du peuple de la nation et de son
armée pour célèbre la crise la création
de l'armée moderne de la nation moderne
et de la république
donc on pensait que c'était
essentiellement le symbole plus que
l'image est donc très vite en arrivant
ici on s'est dit on va donc promener les
gens sur le site on marquera le site et
à l'endroit où le site sera marqué on
tâchera de se rappeler ce qu'il s'est
passé à cet endroit et c'est seulement
par l'émotion qu'en fin de compte les
gens se rappelleront valmy et une
émotion sens contemporain
musique l'original accompagnement sonore
et mise en scène les spectateurs
participants à cette célébration
suivront un parcours d'un kilomètre et
demi une promenade à travers le paysage
les bois et les champs marqués par les
oeuvres contemporaines dans le bois
douze stations pour 12 bataille
populaire sur les chaumes de blé un
couloir dont les parois en tissu
masqueront le paysage qui sera visible
seulement par des fenêtres une relecture
du lieu historique pour la mémoire
cette bataille mis fin à l'invasion de
la france révolutionnaire le 20
septembre 1792 dumouriez et kellerman
remportait la victoire sur les armées
prussiennes le lendemain la république
était proclamée à paris deux siècles
après la bataille on prépare la dernière
grande parade du bicentenaire depuis
trois mois
l'armée a investi la position avec
l'intendance et matériels des artistes
avec leur créativité et leur imagination
le colonel qui commande les troupes
organise la cohabitation des militaires
et de l'avant garde artistique française
plutôt l'habitude de travailler seul et
là bas c'était valmy à laval me c'est la
rencontre d'une nation et son armée
alors on en a profité pour faire
rencontrer les créateurs civils et
militaires qu'est-ce qui vous demandent
des choses un peu qui vous paraissent un
sens et dans tout ce qui est musique et
du spectacle lors celui qui le montrent
avec ses moyens budgets et puis nous on
lui apporte tout ce que le budget peut
pas lui apporter
c'est à dire de la main d'oeuvre
les secrets de nos armées un de nos
moyens militaires
je ne dévoilerai pas ici et qui lui
permettent de réaliser son site sur la
sphère dans le temps achicourt qui a pas
prêt à partir
les travaux d'aménagement et les
répétitions vont bon train pour total du
spectacle 15 millions de francs une
goutte d'eau par rapport à l'ensemble du
bicentenaire les organisateurs attendent
18000 spectateurs et 250 habitants de la
petite commune de valmy ne sont pas
prêts d'oublier cette invasion pacifique
à retenir du week-end sportif le pied de
nez d'alain prost qui a remporté le
grand prix d'italie de formule 1 sur le
circuit de monza ce qui le place en
excellente position pour empêcher un
nouveau titre de champion du monde des
pilotes de formule 1 alain prost en
délicatesse avec ses employeurs mclaren
depuis qu'il a annoncé son transfert
chez ferrari ce qui a fait d'ailleurs la
joie des supporters italiens toleman
c'est certainement le tournant de la
saison ayrton senna en tête du grand
prix d'italie casse son moteur et
abandonne alain prose alors second passe
eelv a remporté sa 39e victoire une
victoire acquise avec un peu de chance
c'est vrai mais sans cela il n'aurait
jamais pu gagner à la régulière
c'était je pensais impossible même s'il
revenait un peu sur lui un moment
la voiture ça les gens avec un peu mieux
mais au niveau moteur et inversement il
voir je pense c'est pour ça que c'est un
peu frustrant à peine les temps même si
c'est un point d'avancé sur prêts encore
très confiant possible
tout reste possible d'autant plus que
senna avant son abandon avait réussi une
belle course après un excellent départ
fidèle à son habitude il est resté 45
tours en tête comptant jusqu'à 22
secondes d'avancé sur ses poursuivants
mais derrière prost réagi parti 4e il
dépasse tout d'abord son futur équipier
mais également de sel puis l'autre
pilote de ferrari
gerard berg r il est alors secondes puis
premier avec la mise à pied
bertone senna alain prost impose donc
devant berg est requis marque ses
premiers points cette année
thierry boutsen riccardo patrese et jean
alesi aux championnats du monde le
français compte désormais 20 points
d'avancé sur le brésilien pour la plus
grande joie des tifosi qui prennent
cette victoire comme le premier cadeau
du petit français puis victoire sans
surprise au bol d'or motocycliste du
castellet honda a dominé la course du
départ à l'arrivée marque maison de le
bol d'or n'est plus tout à fait une
course de 24 heures la foule envahit la
piste l'épreuve s'achève avec un quart
d'heure d'avancé depuis le départ donné
samedi à 15 heures
la domination les deux as du sinn a été
complète
à peine si elle a été perturbée dans les
premiers tours par la suzuki de moineaux
krine et morillas la moto numéro 2 de
mattioli burnett et vire a remporté
l'épreuve presque facilement domination
d'une moto peut-être talent des pilotes
sans aucun doute
alex vieira est aujourd'hui le meilleur
pilote du monde sur ce type de machine
la déception la chute sans gravité
debout et ben provoque la disparition de
la kawasaki l'inquiétude à 6h45
le brouillard la course est neutralisée
à 7h50
elle va reprendre pour que l'épreuve
soit homologué il faut qu'elle bur au
moins 18 heures les deux motos d'usiné
honda reprennent la tête de l'épreuve à
trois tours derrière maîtriser la suzuki
alex vieira en gagnant une nouvelle fois
ce bol d'or aura remporté toutes les
épreuves de la saison d'endurance
voilà c'est à moi il y avait un tiercé
cet après midi qui se courait à
longchamp pour le gagner eh bien il
fallait jouer dans l'ordre le 5 le 6 et
le 1
et pour ce qui concerne le quarté et
bien ajouter à ces trois chiffres
le neuf et vous gagnez un peu plus de
16000 second voilà ce journal est
terminée tout de suite après les
prévisions météo avec josé blanc la
pierre philippe gassot pour les toutes
dernières informations aux alentours de
23 heures demain matin 7h 45 françois
ponchaud les recevra bernard deleu place
secrétaire général du syndicat policier
l'afaspa propos du mécontentement actuel
des policiers qui vient s'ajouter à
celui de la gendarmerie et de certains
militaires un thème que je reprendrai
mardi soir dans star à la barre qui est
intitulé police officielle police
parallèle et nos invités principaux
seront les anges gardiens qui font
régner la loi dans le métro de new york
et qui ont envie de venir s'implanter en
europe et notamment en france
quant au journal de 20 heures demain
soir il vous sera présenté par christine
ockrent dans le tout nouveau décor des
journaux de la rédaction d'antenne quant
à moi je vous dis donc bon soir à mardi
soir et puis à samedi avec toute
l'équipe du week-end bonsoir